I think every little detail you add it
to a song is part of the reason why you
like it so much a welcome one stream
thanking us really crazy foot want you
to see it don't watch X do it
[Music]
I am going to tell you about the most
incredible place and you know what
you're walking on it you know so when
you're looking at those images you know
I had a chance to see some of that from
space and if you go around the planet
every 90 minutes you see a sunrise and a
sunset every 45 minutes and your final
replaces it like you know Afghanistan
and I walk places where there was
fighting in wars but you don't see any
of that from space you just see beauty
so I've always been a huge fan up there
in turn off ski I got really excited
when I heard that he was doing this what
was your experience working with him you
know what he's putting together now with
one strange rock is this is this visual
palette with all these different shapes
and colors and sounds and things but
it's like it takes you to a whole nother
level about learning about your planet
he's brilliant
so you saw the visual spectrum of this
incredible footage and planet I can't
wait to hear the acoustic spectrum
that's you're gonna be I can't get out
well it's really interesting because a
lot of little things that you know make
a grant picture right do you sit down it
in one take and write the song it's a
very long process I like to start with
the on the piano with the harmony of the
melody that's that that's the bass and I
record it all in MIDI and bring it to my
computer and there's several stages of
adding little bits and pieces samples
drums shakers experiment you go through
200 kicks one two three four five six
seven until you hear that one that you
think is right and then you manipulate
that when you slowly build your song
structure and you mix it all together
and then you bounce out one little file
that's what people listen to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you